bonsoir 18h nouvelle édition du 78 lactu
le journal de la rédaction sur TVfil 78
nous sommes le 12 mars nous allons tout
de suite débuter avec l'entretien avec
le docteur Pierre foldz bonsoir merci
d'être venu sur ce plateau cofondateur
de l'Institut en santé génésique à
Saint-Germain en lait l'institut qui est
ouvert depuis le mois de janvier il
vient d'être inauguré c'était en fin de
semaine dernière nous allons d'ailleurs
dans un instant revenir sur cet
événement mais on va tout de même déjà
préciser que c'est un lieu unique en
France pilote les femmes victimes de
violence et qui peuvent venir vous voir
comment est né ce ce projet tout
simplement déjà ce projet est né d'un
vécu commun à plusieurs d'entre nous euh
qui avions eu à faire face dans nos
pratiques professionnelles diverses à
des femmes victimes de violence de
diverses formes de violence et on
s'était aperçu que ces femmes étaient
très mal prises en charge quand on a
étudié un petit peu la littérature
c'était dramatique parce que moins de 1
% des femmes victimes du violence
arrivrive à la plainte et puis on s'est
aperçu que le 78 était pas du tout à
l'abri he il y a pas que le 93 dans les
violences faites aux femmes c'est un
grand département très divers avec des
zones rurales et des zones très diverses
sur le plan citadin et les violences
sont partout et elles sont très très
fortes sur on prend les bonnes
statistiques c'est un un département qui
est très très exposé et on a avait envie
de créer notre projet pilote dans ce
département je vais juste apporter tout
de même une précision pour débuter ce
cette séquence la presse a beaucoup
parlé de l'instittu moment bien sûr du
de l'inauguration du lancement le plus
souvent en mettant en avant votre
travail dans la lutte contre l'excision
puisque je le reprécise vous êtes
l'inventeur de la chirurgie réparatrice
des mutilations sexuelles féminines mais
le centre n'accueille pas uniquement ces
femmes pour être bien clair pour être
bien clair c'est un c'est dédié à toutes
les violence faites aux femmes les
mtilations sont une toute petite partie
chez nous des des violences faites aux
femmes c'est une violence comme une
autre on va se rendre justement dans vos
locaux à Saint-Germain vendredi dernier
se tenait à cette inauguration avec
votre marine Florence Foresti le
reportage de yolen Torz et de Claire
Cambier les locaux de l'Institut en
santé génésique ont été inaugurés il y a
quelques jours des locaux prêts à
accueillir les femmes victimes de toutes
les violences physiques morales ou
encore économique et les professionnels
à leur écoute médecins infirmièrees
psychologu assistantes sociales et
juristes tous bénévoles sont réunis sur
le site et travaillent ensemble pour
aider C femmes on s'est très vite rendu
compte qu'en fait les femmes en fait
souffraient en silence et quand ell
reprenaient la parole c'est un nouvel
espoir et elle retombait dans le silence
pourquoi parce que le parcours était
morcelé et et pas pérenne et nous nous
engageons dans cette pérénité puisque
nous faisons non seulement une prise en
charge une orientation et un suivi et ça
c'est très important donc on demande à
la femme qu'elle nous autorise en fait à
être contacté pour que l'on puisse
savoir ce qu'elle devient et pour donner
un coup de projecteur sur ce premier
centre consacré à la prise en charge des
femmes victimes de violence Florence
Foresti a accepté d'en être la marine
grâce à Florence nous n'avons jamais
baissé les bras tout simplement parce
que lorsque nous sommes allés la
rencontrer il y a maintenant plus d'un
an et demi la première fois elle nous a
dit oui on on voit très bien que ce sont
des sujets très complexes et que moi je
veux sortir aussi de la victimisation
des femmes oh ces pauvres petites choses
qui peuvent pas se défendre c'est pas ça
c'est beaucoup plus complexe comme on
l'a vu aujourd'hui parce qu'une femme
c'est aussi une mère parce qu'une femme
elle travaille ou pas parce qu'une femme
elle peut encore subir une domination
économique au sein de son couple donc
les les violences faites aux femmes
c'est beaucoup plus qu'une gifle en fin
de repas ce qui est déjà absolument
intolérable mais ça peut être beaucoup
plus subtile que ça et plus c'est
subtile plus c'est difficile de leur
venir en aide dans ce domaine les ivline
n'ont rien à envier aux autres
départements les cas de violence
mortelle contre les femmes y sont parmi
les plus nombreux
c'est le 5e département le plus touché
en France depuis son ouverture le 6
janvier 2014 l'Institut en santé
génésique a déjà accueilli plus d'une
trentaine de femmes ça nous a surpris on
aurait préféré en avoir moins quelque
part parce que on se serait dit que l'on
s'est trompé et en fait on ne s'est pas
trompé on a constaté que à peine cette
porte ouverte onarrive même plus à tenir
nos permanence elles viennent quand
elles peuvent le soir après le travail
en allant chercher le pain par exemple
voilà et on on est très très frappé par
la précarité de ces femmes qui
effectivement s'inscrivent dans quelque
chose d'extrêmement douloureux c'est une
une détresse effectivement psychologique
mais extrêmement
euh économique puisqu'elles arrivent
effectivement sans ressources situé dans
l'enceinte du centre hospitalier
intercommunal de poissis Saint-Germain
en lait le centre financé en partie par
des dons privés n'a bénéficié pour le
moment d'aucune aide de l'État la marine
Florence forestier a lancé une campagne
d'appel au don un geste qui permettrait
de gagner une rencontre avec l'humoriste
à l'occasion de son prochain spectacle
au Théâtre du Châtelet cet automne le
docteur Foldes est l'invité de ce
journal pour ce centre unique dédié aux
femmes victimes de violence rattaché à
l'hôpital de poissis Saint-Germain hly
vous le disiez tout à l'heure ça a été
aussi mentionné dans le reportage le
département des ivelines n'est pas
épargné par ces cas de de violence vous
avez même déjà rencontré une quarantaine
de femmes hein depuis l'ouverture au
mois de janvier quels sont les types de
violence auxquelles font face les femmes
et et qui ensuite viennent vous voir et
on a choisi de pas caractériser les
violences en fait les violences se
retrouvent dans plusieurs cadres le
cadre de la famille avec les violences
conjugales qui sont très très nombreuses
le cadre du travail et puis le cadre de
la société en général donc on a choisi
de de pas Serrier les choses et on voit
tout les types de violences du du viol à
l'inceste à la violence habituelle qu'on
peut voir dans la rue
et un point très très important c'était
de pas être Stig matisant c'est-à-dire
de pas privilégier une catégorie plutôt
qu'une autre et faire un espace
totalement ouvert où n'importe quel type
de violence pouvait être accueilli ça
c'était très important j'im que vous
nous expliquz justement comment se passe
la prise en charge de de ces femmes
lorsqu'elles arrivent lorsqu'elles vous
contacte que se passe-t-il parce que
déjà il faut libérer la parole et c'est
déjà peut-être la première difficulté
voà donc le le le grand point
d'achopppement de ces prises en charge
pour l'instant c'est c'est le tout début
c'est pour ça qu'on est vraiment un
projet de prévention on est vraiment en
amont de la plainte on est dans la
détection et la prévention c'est un un
problème de de de médecine préventive et
justement la médecine était pas très
très au fait des violences jusqu'à
maintenant et pas dans les circuits de
réponse donc on va essayer de créer une
interface conviviale non stigmatisante
on est à la fois dans l'hôpital dans un
espace de soins assez bien identifié
mais on n'est pas dans l'hôpital non
plus on est proche de la rue
complètement au centre-ville et les
femmes peuvent venir de façon totalement
anonyme et elles vont là essayer de
libérer leur parole pour la première
fois et ce qu'on a vu c'est des femmes
qui attendaient des années des dizaines
d'années d'avoir ce genre de situation
même qui avait déjà contacté des
associations puis qui avait pas trouvé
tout à fait les réponses elles sont
orienté vers des professionnels ce sont
des professionnels il y a des
accueillants qui sont soit des
infirmières soit des assistantes
sociales et qui vont faire un premier
une première libération de la parole on
va savoir un petit peu ce qui se passe
et juste derrière les les professionnels
sont là dans ce même lieu et dans ce
même temps il y a une unité de lieu et
de temps et cette femme si elle le veut
elle est pas du tout poussée de façon
inductive mais elle va pouvoir voir un
médecin pou avoir un psychologue à P
avoir un juriste à pouir avoir une
assistente sociale pour régler des
problèmes d'hébergement par exemple et
tout ça en même temps donc c'est ça le
principe c'est d'essayer de voir ce dont
peut avoir besoin tout ce dont peut
avoir besoin une femme victime de
violence et lui offrir le début de cette
prise en charge et ce sont des
professionnels qui répondent à ces
besoins des des les femmes victimes de
violence et aussi on va le préciser le
repréciser ce sont des bénévoles tout le
monde est bien sûr bénévole euh et aussi
la plupart sont des des libéraux ilsus
du monde libéral parce que
l'institutionnel pour l'instant nous
avveit pas séduit dans sa réponse en
revanche nous travaillons la main dans
la main avec le Centre Hospitalier nous
passons des conventions les unes avec
les autres avec notamment le service
d'urgence le service d'orthogénie la
psychiatrie et cetera donc on a réussi à
réunir à peu près toutes les branches de
la médecine mais à la base ce sont des
libéraux bénévoles comment vous
expliquez que justement l'État ne
viennne pas en aide au développement de
tel type de structure je crois que
l'État d'abord c'est assez connu à pas
beaucoup d'argent alors on a une leçon à
donneré à l'état enfin c'est pas une
leçon c'est que on a réussi à calculer
il y a des études très sérieuses dont
l'étude de l'envf qui a maintenant
quelques années le coût des violences
faites aux femmes est absolument
considérable les par exemple un chiffre
qui qu'il faut rappeler les seules
violences conjugales sur un an c'est 4,5
milliards d'euros en coût pour la
société c'est quatre fois le cancer du
sein donc c'est un coût terrible c'est
vraiment un vrai problème de santé
publique donc c'était vraiment
prioritaire pour nous donc l'objectif
c'est aussi de changer le regard des
politiques et de faire pilote un début
seulement et de dév c'est un projet
pilote il faut agir de façon
scientifique et reproductible et prouver
que ce qu'on fait est bien et donc pour
faire changer la politique il faut des
chiffres faut des des chiffres fiables
mes et c'est aussi ce qu'on va faire
alors on va afficher une nouvelle fois
un numéro de téléphone pour ce cells qui
voudrait vous contacter prendre prendre
contact avec l'Institut l'institut est
en basé sur Saint-Germain on la si on
habite dans le reste du département on
peut quand même venir vous voir là aussi
on pr d'abord d'abord il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se font par téléphone avec
les professionnels de santé nous avons
un réseau d'adressage qui s'attend à
tout le département et on peut décrocher
son téléphone un médecin peut avoir un
juriste au téléphone en direct est aidé
dans sa démarche première et nous allons
créer assez rapidement des antenn par
exemple dans la région de Rambouillet ou
dans la région de Manthes des antennes
qui seront en réseau avec nous et qui
vont nous permettre de de traiter plus
directement l'ensemble du département
merci Docteur fold d'être venu sur ce
plateau nous parler de cet institut une
première en France qui vient en aide aux
femmes victimes de violence d'une tout
autre manière une manière novatrice
c'est un institut pilote merci encore
d'être venu sur ce plateau on reste dans
le domaine de la santé avec un reportage
de yolen Torz à présent consacré au
karaté santé c'est une activité physique
idéale pour les articulations système
cardioovasculaire ou encore les troubles
du vieillissement proposé pour la deuxè
année à bois d'Arc cette discipline
permet au senior de pratiquer un sport
de combat adapté à l'âge le reportage de
la
rédaction on accélère
cours la séance démarre avec un
échauffement et toujours en douceur ces
élèves de 50 ans et plus pratiquent un
karaté adapté à leur âge le karaté santé
une discipline proposée à bois d'Arc
pour la 2è année consécutive c'est long
à démarrer parce que les gens euh les
gens qui ont 60 ans si vous voulez
direent je vais faire du karaté euh oh
là là euh je vais me casser ceci cela
alors que c'est pas du tout ça au
contraire beaucoup d'assouplissements et
d'étirements sont au programme
l'objectif est de retrouver une certaine
souplesse du dynamisme mais pas
seulement ce qu'on apprend aussi c'est
de aux gens de se sortir d'une situation
délicate si vous voulez bon euh s'il y a
une prise de main si sont on veut
prendre leur sac si vous voulez des
petites choses comme ça qui leur permet
si vous voulez de se sécuriser de se
sentir un petit peu plus en
confiance parmi les adeptes ceux qui ont
déjà pratiqué le karaté étant jeune
comme Xavier déjà 30 ans de pratique
derrière lui et aujourd'hui grâce au
karaté santé il se concentre moins sur
le combat mais plus sur l'aspect
technique on s'entraîne surtout à notre
rythme parce que c'est vrai que il y a
la problème
du cardioovasculaire donc on peut pas se
permettre non plus d'avoir une activité
trop intense ce qui nous intéresse nous
c'est surtout de d'avoir une activité
complète de faire du sport et puis B je
dirais aussi de se distraire de faire
travailler un petit peu sa tête et ses
neurones puisquil y a quand même
beaucoup de techniqu à apprendre
d'autres en revanche sont totalement
débutants dans la discipline c'est le
cas de Yannick en un peu plus d'un an il
a passé sa ceinture verte et compte bien
accéder au Graal la ceinture noire mat
de marque qui était un peu style bourrin
donc je me suis méfié hein je suis
méfiant de nature donc quand on m'a
présenté les choses j'ai dit bon ok
c'est un chon je fais j'y vais B j'aime
bien le sport et au bout de 3 semaines à
mois les profs ils m'ont posé la
questions bon Yan est-ce que ça te
convient euh est-ce que tu veux qu'on
amélior le chos ou tu vas arrêter quoi
bah surprenant donc je suis parti et
puis parti à fond quoi maintenant c'est
c'est c'est une passion
quoi tout autre sujet à présent le
partenariat entre ERD DF Électricité de
France et les pompiers du 10 78 a été
renouvelé fin 2013 le but former les
professionnels du feu au risque
électrique notamment via des simulations
d'accidents c'est un sujet d'Olivier
Maniscalco et d'éodim
moine une formation pour se prévenir des
risques électriques en partenariat avec
DF une quinzaine de pompiers du S 78 a
pu bénéficier d'exercices pratiques sur
le site de carrière souspoissie
vérification d'absence de tension dans
un compteur électrique ou intervention
auprès d'une victime à proximité d'un
câble à haute tension le tout coaché par
des techniciens ERDF qui inculquent au
sapeur pompiers leur
savoir-faireavance avec la tablette et
j'écarte le cécarte le câble de par
leurs interventions les Sapur pompiers
sont bien souvent d'abord dans un état
de stress important et effectivement
toujours soumis au risque électrique
environnant donc il était important de
les sensibiliser au bon geste donc vous
l'avez vu aujourd'hui avec cette
simulation
d'un câble à terre aujourd'hui c'est ce
qui a été d'ailleurs à l'origine de la
sensibilisation dans le département des
evvines c'est ces nouvelles sources
d'énergie qui sont apparu il y a
quelques années et principalement le
photovoltaïque les agents de RDF sont
les sachants c'est eux qui vont donc
nous former pour se protéger du risque
électrique et éviter tout accident de
personnes et également de sa pompier 5
ou si opérations par an de ce type
devrai perfectionner la formation des
sapeurs pompiers même si le nombre
d'accidents diminue depuis 30 ans une
dizaine de personnes meurent chaque
année d'électrocution en France et 20 %
des incendies sont d'origine électrique
néanmoins jusqu'à présent aucun accident
grave ou mortel n'a encore été relevé
chez les pompiers dans les
ivelines l'actuevient demain 18h en
direct n'oubliez pas votre soirée sur
TVfil c'est avec Aurelia debici pour une
nouvelle édition nouveau numéro de
kiosque le magazine de la culture bonne
soirée